speaking at this guy's meteorologist
kirsty mccabe because he is in surrey
for us hi kirsty so it's going to be
hotter than it was yesterday but do you
think it's going to get up to 42 degrees
oh it's a very good question it's
already a good seven or eight degrees
hotter now than it was at the same time
yesterday morning
and the probabilities of exceeding 40
have increased to around 80 percent we
could get 41 106 fahrenheit 42. well
it's not out of the question and if
you'd asked me this a few weeks ago
where i said no it's an outside chance
but we knew at the end of june that
there was a possibility we could get 40
in the middle of july and now as we got
closer to the day the probability has
increased it's certainly been a very
very hot start this morning but
temperatures as we saw through today
could reach 41 degrees now it's an area
really london area up towards
cambridgeshire probably most likely also
towards them yorkshire as well up
towards available we could see these
high high numbers we've never had above
40 in the uk before the current record
is 38.7 and there's a greater than 95
chance we will beat that today uh the
rest of the week though well very
different we're going to see uh all
change tomorrow dropping back down to
just 30. but that's still pretty hot now
i mentioned how hot it had been last
night if you're difficulty sleeping this
might explain why these are actually the
minimum temperatures and these are more
like you'd expect during the day so
overnight temperatures dropped down
um as low as um 25.9 was the end in
emily moore but actually 25.8 is the
official minimum record at kenley
airfield that's just south of london so
we're going to see another very warm
warm day today the top temperatures
we're expecting today and so those
aren't the highs those are the actual
minimum temperatures so that's the
official four warmest places through the
night last night 25.8 in kenley just
south of london as we go through the day
today though as i mentioned we are going
to see many places not just in the south
of england or eastern england we're
going to see right across the country
temperatures widely up into the 30s for
example whales had its hottest day
yesterday so did northern ireland parts
of jersey so we're all seeing these
really high high numbers
today is the peak of the heat but as you
saw the numbers will start to drop off
as we go through the rest of the week
and we'll see some showers coming in
fact already thunderstorms are looming
out towards the southwest so the heat
wave is fairly short-lived but it is
very intense and the peak of the heat
will be probably in a couple of hours
time we're looking at
one two three in the afternoon tend to
be the hottest times of day so we'll
keep you updated at the moment i'm on my
garden thermometer um
about 35 here so we are
rapidly heading towards a 40 degree mark
elsewhere we've been seeing temperatures
reaching 35 36 so it's not going to be
long now until we surpass the uk's
record temperature
okay kirsty thank you so much